-Salut Romain...
-Julien, y a quoi dans le sperme?
Comment tu vas? Moi ça va, merci de demander...
-Pourquoi tu veux savoir ça?
-Ben on m'a dit que c'était super précieux, j'ai vraiment besoin d'argent et je voudrais vendre le mien.
On raconte beaucoup de choses sur le sperme, alors parfois parce que ça arrange les gens mais on va en reparler,
parfois juste parce que ça fascine. Un liquide capable de créer la vie.
Bon, pas tout seul hein, quand même, j'le rappelle. Un liquide qu'on peut produire sur commande, à condition d'être équipé et qui donne du plaisir
quand on le fait, j'avoue...
Y'a une espèce de délire
presque mystique autour du sperme.
Du coup ça me paraît important de remettre un peu les choses à leur place et de regarder ça d'un peu plus près,
façon de parler hein, pour voir ce qu'il y a vraiment dedans. Et oui,  je sais exactement à quoi m'attendre avec cette vidéo
tant pis pour la démonétisation *Roubignolles*. Bon déjà le sperme c'est pas juste un fluide corporel c'est plusieurs fluides corporels.
C'est pour ça que c'est pas toujours très homogène, donc oui le sperme c'est un cocktail
et comme vous êtes sympas je vais vous donner la recette.
♫ Sperme, sperme, sperme, on est tous du sperme, sperme, sperme, à la base ♫
♫ Sperme, sperme, on est tous du.. sperme ... à la base ♫
Pour réaliser la recette du sperme vous aurez besoin du matériel suivant:
Un verre doseur
Un shaker
du sopalin
et...
Surtout pas de glaçons c'est un cocktail qui donne le meilleur de lui même à température ambiante. Passons aux ingrédients maintenant, il vous faut:
3,25 millilitres de liquide séminal
1 millilitre de sécrétions prostatiques
0.5 millilitres de sécrétions et épididymaire, 0,2 millilitres de liquide pré-éjaculatoire
0,05 millilitres de spermatozoïdes. Versez l'ensemble des ingrédients dans le shaker
Saisissez le shaker dans une main et le sopalin dans l'autre. Secouez vigoureusement jusqu'à ce que ce soit prêt
Et voilà! C'est prêt. Vous avez préparé l'équivalent d'un éjaculat moyen c'est à dire environ
5 millilitres de sperme, soit le contenu d'une cuillère à café
Il est possible qu'il y ait quelques grumeaux, ne vous inquiétez pas ça n'est pas grave
et ça ne remet pas en cause la qualité du cocktail. Ça apporte même un peu de texture, ça donne un côté bubble tea.
Au revoir
♫ Sperme, sperme, sperme, on est tous du sperme, sperme, sperme, à la base ♫
♫ Sperme, sperme, sperme, on est tous du.. sperme ... à la base ♫
C'est vrai pour les grumeaux, vraiment c'est rien du tout. Parfois le sperme est un peu plus visqueux donc ça donne cette apparence mais
ça change rien à sa qualité donc pas de soucis. Bon donc maintenant vous savez ce qu'il y a dans le cocktail
mais on va faire un petit tour tout au long de la chaîne de fabrication des produits. Alors les spermatozoïdes, les cellules reproductrices
elles sont fabriquées là dans les testicules mais vous avez vu ça représente que 1% du volume total du sperme
Avant de sortir, ils sont mélangés avec le fluide qui est produit au niveau de l'épididyme
- dont on a déjà parlé dans la vidéo sur le syndrome des couilles bleues - et qui se trouve ici.
A ce stade là on n'a pas plus de 10 à 11% du produit fini. La mixture passe ensuite par le canal déférent, juste ici
hop hop hop hop hop elle fait tout le tour et elle arrive jusqu'au niveau des vésicules séminales
qui produisent le liquide du même nom. Là on tient le bon bout on a déjà plus de
75 % du volume total du sperme. La prostate ajoute ses sécrétions là on monte à
95% et tous ça, ça patiente dans la rampe de lancement
juste ici qui s'appelle le canal éjaculateur. Le reste est produit
ici par la glande de Cooper c'est le fameux liquide pré-éjaculatoire appelé aussi liquide pré-séminal.
Il va être attrapé au passage mais lui il a déjà pris un peu d'avance en fait
parce que le liquide pré-séminal il sert à deux choses:
Faire baisser l'acidité dans l'urètre avant l'arrivée des spermatozoïdes
ils aiment pas trop ça quand c'est acide
Et il sert aussi de lubrifiant, il est sécrété dès le début de la réaction et il sort avant sans qu'on le sente. Du coup il faut se méfier parce que
Un: ok il contient pas de spermatozoïdes mais il peut en rester dans l'urètre d'une précédente
éjaculation du coup lui il va les amener vers la sortie
et en cas de rapport il peut y avoir fécondation.
Deux: des études ont montré que le VIH était présent dedans, chez les personnes séropositives
donc il peut être contaminant.
Surtout qu'il sort un peu quand il le sent. Bon mais les autres liquides à quoi ils servent?
Le liquide présent au niveau de l'épididyme il sert à transporter les spermatozoïdes et à les aider à
poursuivre leur maturation. C'est une sorte de chaperon, hein, il les conduits et il les booste un peu parce que la première fois qu'ils sortent
ils sont pas complètement finis les tétards. Le liquide produit au niveau des vésicules séminales lui c'est un peu le ravitaillement,
il est chargé de nourrir les spermatozoïdes et de leur permettre de tenir la distance. Oui parce que quand toute la machinerie se met en branle
tout ce petit monde pars du principe qu'on est parti pour un road trip jusqu'à un ovule.
En réalité, ça se termine pas toujours comme ça
vous même vous savez
Sopaliiiiiiin, nooooooon
Mais dans le doute pour le voyage les vésicules séminales elles ont prévu de quoi tenir le coup. Elles ont prévu du fructose et
différentes substances comme des prostaglandines et des protéines qui sont chargées de
favoriser la fécondation et de protéger les spermatozoïdes
pendant le trajet. Et donc les sécrétions prostatiques, elles, elles contiennent des substances qui stimulent la mobilité des spermatozoïdes
et qui poursuivent leur maturation. Le sperme contient aussi des vitamines et des sels minéraux:
phosphore, magnésium, potassium, calcium, zinc, etc... Voilà! Au final,
mais vous connaissez peut-être je ne sais pas, le cocktail il est translucide avec une couleur
blanchâtre voir un peu jaunâtre. Parfois il est très transparent, parfois il est très jaune c'est normal ça dépend juste du dosage des différents ingrédients.
Alors si il est rouge par contre, il peut y avoir du sang dedans
c'est pas forcément grave mais ça mérite quand même d'aller en parler au médecin.
Bon ben et l'odeur alors? Et ben ce sont les protéines
contenues dans le sperme qui lui donnent cette odeur caractéristique
même si elle peut varier d'un individu à l'autre.
Toujours question de dosage comme pour n'importe quel cocktail. Et au sujet du goût?
Eh ben, il peut varier aussi, pour les mêmes raisons et aussi par rapport à l'alimentation.
Il y a des aliments qui peuvent modifier le goût du sperme.
Alors en bien ou en mal hein,
ça c'est juste une question de goût justement.
Mais on peut quand même retenir que le café, le tabac, l'alcool
niveau saveur c'est pas terrible. Pareil pour les oignons, l'ail, les brocolis ou les choux de bruxelles.
Par contre les fruits genre les nectarines ou la mangue, c'est pas mal et aussi la menthe, la camomille et le thé vert.
"De savoureux mélanges de plantes et d'arômes !"
Il y a même des petits malins qui vendent des pilules qui donnent bon goût au sperme
Boh, puisqu'on en est là, y a quand même un truc dont il faut qu'on parle. Y a une espèce de kif très répandu autour de la spermophagie.
Du latin sperma, la semence donc le sperme, et du grec Phagos, manger
Ok, donc pour ceux qu'ont pas fait de langue morte avaler, là vous l'avez nan?
Du coup on raconte
énormément de choses sur les bienfaits du sperme en tant que complément alimentaire.
Bon on va pas faire le tour de tout ce qui se raconte non plus, mais quand même, pour résumer:
Oui, le sperme c'est plein de bonnes choses pour seulement 15 à 30 calories par éjaculats c'est-à-dire un ou deux apéricubes.
"Saumon, mon préféré!"
Voire un peu moins. Donc, effectivement ça fait pas grossir mais attention!
Ça fait pas maigrir non plus, non.
Ça c'est faux. ah et on lit aussi un peu partout qu'un éjaculat, oui j'aime bien ce mot,
un éjaculat contiendrait autant de protéines qu'un oeuf. On lit ça partout sans vraiment savoir d'où ça vient.
Et en réalité c'est probablement beaucoup moins. Et au sujet des éléments qui composent le sperme et qui sont censés avoir mille vertus
antioxydantes ou être bon pour les cheveux ou être bon pour la peau etc, etc... En réalité faudrait
vraiment en consommer quotidiennement une grosse quantité pour que ce soit vraiment efficace.
Bon si vous cherchez des produits anti-âge, ou que vous voulez prendre soin de vos cheveux ou de votre peau
faut quand même savoir que dans le commerce y a des produits qui ont été mis au point
exprès pour ça. Après si vraiment vous êtes branché bukkake moi juge pas
♫ Sperme, sperme, sperme, on est tous du.. sperme... ♫
d'ailleurs c'est ça le truc au fond, avec cette histoire de spermophagie, c'est comme avec toutes les pratiques sexuelles.
Pas la peine d'aller inventer des histoires,
faites-le si vous en avez envie, et ne le faites pas si vous n'en avez pas envie ou plus envie. Et surtout évidemment
essayez pas de forcer quelqu'un qui a pas envie de le faire. Alors dernière chose avant de se quitter
il y a un autre truc que le sperme peut contenir: Le VIH ou tout type d'infections sexuellement transmissibles.
Donc en deux mots:
dépistage et protection.
J'vous remet un petit lien dans la description, ça peut pas faire de mal.
Vous l'avez compris, oui le sperme c'est vachement bien, mais c'est pas non plus de l'ambroisie ni de l'or
liquide, pas la peine d'aller braquer une banque du sperme.
D'ailleurs on peut donner son sperme, c'est même bien le faire, il y a des gens qui en ont besoin
mais c'est gratuit, c'est pas rémunéré.
Ça répond à ta question du coup Romain.
Voilà, DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui, on se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo,
d'ici là prenez soin de vous et prenez soin des autres, prenez soin de votre sperme et de celui des êtres qui vous sont chers,
mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien.
♫ Sperme, sperme, sperme, on est tous du sperme, sperme, sperme, à la base ♫
♫ Sperme sperme, sperme, on est tous du.. sperme ... à la base ♫